there was almost a state for first
Americans it was a state called Sequoia
back when Europeans were expanding West
taking over North America the newly
formed United States government bought
all of this land but there was a little
issue which is that there are a bunch of
native people living on this land and
they had been for thousands of years so
the US government decided that they
would buy the land and sign treaties
with the people living on it and ask
them to leave and they did but spoiler
alert it was all the tribes
that didn't want to leave were literally
forcibly removed and put out into the
Great Plains we call this the Trail of
Tears and it brought loads of these
tribes to live in this one place this
one rectangle called Indian Territory
eventually settler starts showing up
they start carving up this whole area
there's lots of maps and all of this
eventually gets turned into a new
territory called Oklahoma territory okay
but what about the state that the native
people made for themselves check it out
in part two in the comments